yeah welcome a new video called you for
playing against a fellow german
international master here i always
forget goonter bike out yeah pretty good
I am so he's some above 2400 for ages
from southern Germany I think hope
that's correct so we got an Enzo and I
like to experiment with the sameish
variation at some always leading to UM
to interesting play if like takes on c3
he didn't were just probably probably
playable why not intending to go d5 next
the question is should I play Knight f3
now and just after d5 player Queens
gambit were cut the extra move a 3 or is
there something else I could go a form
and on d5 play with e 5 yeah maybe
I'm not sure how to go about that but
let's let's just just just develop let's
just develop him using the time a three
can can be ma useful extra move I play
Bishop d3 d2 and Roxy one
uh-huh
interesting look we should be seven
there's some some big big @dm behind
this
okay I wonder about Bishop b5 p.m. it
should be five there should be seven
Queen a4 a6 c6 he can go be five this is
problematic but still Knight e5 may be
Queen a4 a6 if I take on these seven is
this some some some idea probably not
hmm
maybe we should be five wasn't so good
so he got dumb the hanging pawns
I try this Knight e5 plan 95 and f4 this
should be quite um quite good position
for black I mean one needs to be M
realistic the Sun certainly wasn't so
great for me all this let's take him
with then maybe this isn't so bad after
all this controls this diagonal bd22 a
five so we cannot easily advance the
pawns and maybe I have f5 and send and
ideas like that
yeah maybe exchange this Bishop is it
isn't a great piece Bishop c2 ok one
them to make sure that he is not able to
play a five useless majority and also we
need to catch up a bit on the clock but
it is not so wow really ok I must be
completely blind here do I miss some
some obvious stuff may okay can we can
do this but still that's really good can
can give away all this really hmm a five
and tone okay so i go here and if he
takes I exchange playbooks you want some
ok so I've got an extra porn which ok I
admit is not the greatest extra corn
Adam maybe I can get the bishop to
attack the porn here cooking f1 Bishop
e2 and then maybe I'll end up with an
extra porn after all
you can go look to be five and then
Bishop e2 takes on a five exchange
everything
hmm
can't this is quite quite tricky
can't maybe route before back I can
campisi basically I think playing on
time I mean it's not you cannot this is
not playing on position this is just a
better end game for me this is not not
an asset this pawn it's just a weakness
I'm John he needs to guard it all the
time it's got all the porns on light
squares which is Sir which is a
liability okay
so I'm how to win this no f5 / should be
six maybe no way to know where can I can
just grab this pawn okay who could have
taken it instantly of course but you
didn't see that yeah this is fairly
simple now I will just grab the e porn
also so probably the easiest just King
defined pick up the poem yeah just get
to get this pawn and then two pawns up
yeah maybe you should have just settled
for the draw I mean I'm not I'm not sure
it's not easy I've got the sixth rippon
but then I will probably lose a five I
don't really see um you know computer
gives white just just a winning
advantage yeah Brooke a three rook ca1
there may be about this also good yeah
again this is actually quite an
interesting endgame is this winning it's
um it looks it looks tricky for black he
always always tied to the pawns and here
here maybe G success is the more
tenacious defense I think I need to take
and then try to to get around here with
the bishop to e8 or something yeah a
threatening look Bishop the age to this
have now winning this this pawn and it
looks like I'm winning a porn anyway how
does he a does prevent
dad let's say he drops back here Bishop
to e8 I know no this is this is nonsense
I just go here of course and then I get
this pawn just just back to e2 and take
it of course this means he cannot he
cannot miss the the King in this
position of course and yeah then it's
probably probably gone if he play
something like this yeah and this has
got this problem yeah quite nice at the
end to send game yeah thanks for
watching an interesting game